en el vídeo anterior vimos la
sustitución núcleo física aromática con
una reacción de adición y eliminación en
este vídeo veremos una reacción de
adición y eliminación con la formación
de bencina como intermediario empezamos
con bromo benceno y agregaremos a medida
de sodio que es una base fuerte y
amoniaco líquido observen que
sustituimos el halógeno por el grupo am
y no formando anilina como nuestro
producto echemos un vistazo al mecanismo
empezaremos con la parte de eliminación
eliminación nuestra amiga de sodio
funcionará como una base entonces
dibujemos el avión por aquí la base toma
este protón dejando estos electrones en
el carbón dibujemos el resultado de esta
reacción ha sido base aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo
el grupo saliente y tenemos una carga
formal negativa en este carbono hemos
formado un kart baño resaltemos algunos
electrones
estos electrones formaron el carbón ión
que se encuentra en la posición norte
respecto al grupo saliente ahora si
estos electrones se mueven hacia el
anillo formarán un triple enlace eso
permite que estos electrones se puedan
ir junto con el halógeno que se
convierte en unión y así es como hemos
creado una molécula de bencina estos
electrones formaron un triple enlace
pero este es un intermediario muy
inestable resulta que esta molécula es
muy reactiva así que el siguiente paso
es la adición
aquí tenemos nuestra molécula de bencina
y está molecular reaccionará con el año
navidad pero esta vez el año funcionará
como núcleo filo y atacar a uno de los
carbonos del triple enlace digamos que
ataca de este lado lo que empujará a
estos electrones de regreso a este
carbono dibujemos el resultado aquí
tenemos nuestro anillo y ahora tenemos
un nh 2 unido al anillo y estos
electrones entonces los electrones en
rosa se movieron para formar nuevamente
un carbón en la posición org bien y
nuestro último paso es la protón acción
del anillo así que una molécula de
amoniaco entra y funcionará como un
ácido donar a un protón así que estos
electrones en rosa toman un protón
dejando estos electrones finalmente
hemos formado anilina como nuestro
producto
ok veamos un problema aquí tenemos un
anillo de sustituido los sustituye entes
se encuentran en posición para respecto
al otro y agregaremos samira de sodio
que tiene una carga formal negativa
entonces el primer paso es la
eliminación
lo primero que ocurre es una reacción
ácido base nuestra unidad tomará un
protón que se encuentra cerca del
halógeno podría tomar este protón o esté
en este caso no importa cual ya que es
una molécula asimétrica digamos que
tomará este protón dejando estos
electrones en el carbono dibujemos el
resultado aquí tenemos nuestro anillo un
grupo metilo y nuestro halógeno y ahora
tenemos una carga formal negativa en
este carbono entonces estos electrones
se moverán para formar un triple enlace
empujando estos electrones que se irán
junto con el grupo saliente
pero se va y así formamos nuestro vecino
como intermediario este es nuestro
vecino y recuerden que escogí este
protón para la reacción ha sido base
pero pudo haber sido este entonces
obtenemos nuestro vecino y lo haremos
reaccionar con nuestra vida que ahora
funcionará como núcleo filo y podría
atacar por cualquier lado del triple
enlace pero si ataca por este lado estos
electrones se moverán hacia acá
dibujemos el resultado aquí tenemos
nuestro anillo nuestro nh 2 un par de
electrones libres y nuestro grupo metilo
ahora si el núcleo filo ataca de este
lado del triple enlace empujaría los
electrones hacia este carbono dibujemos
lo que resultaría nuevamente tenemos
nuestro anillo el grupo metilo y ahora
agregamos nuestro nh 2 del lado derecho
y aquí nos queda el par de electrones
libres
finalmente sólo necesitamos protón ar el
anillo no mostraré el mecanismo pero
dibujemos los productos en este caso
nuestros grupos nos quedan en posición
para respecto al otro y en este caso nos
quedan en posición meta así que
obtendremos una mezcla de productos
veamos otro tipo de reacción de
eliminación utilizando este mecanismo
esta vez en lugar de usar a mida de
sodio usaremos hidróxido de sodio que
también es una base fuerte calentaremos
y necesitamos agregar una fuente de
protones observen que al final un grupo
o sustituye a nuestro halógeno esta es
una reacción muy famosa ahora veamos el
problema de abajo aquí tenemos un grupo
metilo y a diferencia del problema
anterior se encuentra en posición metal
respecto al cloro nuevamente pensemos en
el año en hidróxido funcionando como
base
para un protón del anillo recuerden debe
ser un protón que se encuentre junto al
grupo saliente así que podría tomar este
protón oeste pero ahora son dos
posiciones diferentes
así que obtendremos dos intermediarios
pensemos primero en el protón de la
derecha si este protón se va estos
electrones se moverán para formar el
triple enlace dibujemos el resultado con
la eliminación del halógeno nos queda el
vecino éste es un posible intermediario
pero si tomamos este protón el halógeno
sale y nos queda a otro vecino
esta vez el triple enlace se formará
entre este hidrógeno y el cloro justo
aquí observen que los enlaces peak
dentro del anillo están dibujados
diferente pero no hay problema ahora que
ya tenemos nuestros dos posibles
intermediarios en el siguiente paso
nuestro hidróxido funcionará como núcleo
film para este caso pensemos en que el
núcleo filo ataca
de este lado del triple enlace dibujemos
el producto final aquí tenemos nuestro
anillo el grupo metilo y nuestro h en
posición para respecto al grupo metilo
este es un posible producto usaré otro
color para que se vea mejor este ataque
núcleo físico nos daría a este producto
pero si tuviéramos este ataque núcleo
físico obtendríamos un producto
diferente aquí tenemos nuestro anillo
el grupo metilo y ahora hemos agregado
el o h a este carbono entonces hemos
obtenido dos productos diferentes y
podemos hacer lo mismo con esta molécula
dibujemos el producto si el hidróxido
ataca del lado izquierdo del triple
enlace
así quedaría uno de los productos pero
hay otro posible producto podríamos
atacar por el lado derecho del triple
enlace así que para nuestra cuarta
posibilidad aquí tenemos el anillo
nuestro grupo o h y nuestro grupo metil
y bueno si se dan cuenta estos dos
productos son la misma molécula los
electrones
están dibujados diferente pero sabemos
que sólo son estructuras de resonancia
así que en total obtuvimos tres
productos esta sería una molécula 2 y 3
en un examen no tienen mucho tiempo para
dibujar todo el mecanismo pero piensen
en la eliminación del halógeno para
formar su vecino como intermediario
piensen en cuántos intermediarios son
posibles y finalmente piensen en agregar
el núcleo filo en algunos de los lados
del triple enlace eso les dará los
posibles productos para su respuesta